hey there good morning nate we are just
outside mccarran airport as a passenger
here we are approaching the departures
area
let's go ahead and flip the camera to
give you a look so we saw a lot more
cars here earlier just a few minutes ago
so it looks like things are kind of like
a hit or miss they are starting to clear
out we are uh driving just by the
allegiant mc by the allegiance spirit
drop off area for the departure flights
here at terminal one and off to the left
that is where we have the terminal one
long-term parking garage which according
to mccarran is already full but there
are other options bianca holman is live
inside
she's live inside and she'll be breaking
down the best way to navigate through
the area and also your parking options
before we go to bianca though i want to
say
right now is a great time to hit the
road between now and noon but bianca is
live inside we have live team coverage
she's talking all about the flights in
case there are any delays and also the
best way to go ahead and park in case
you are leaving your car and heading out
on a flight bianca
good morning so we're here at the
baggage claim area
right now there is a flight that just
arrived from indianapolis so folks are
grabbing their bags and headed to see
loved ones at the pickup area so also if
you plan to get here we want to give you
some plans and to make your morning as
smooth as can be if you can get someone
to drop you off great if not take a cab
or an uber but if you must drive listen
up we've got this tweet the airport
tweeted out about an hour ago terminal
one long term parking garage has already
reached full capacity if you're trying
to travel from that terminal they're
advising you you can't go there you have
to use terminal 3 garage or the economy
lot that requires you to take a shuttle
so again give yourself at least an hour
to accommodate if you're coming here to
drive and park here at the airport
we're told everyone should give
themselves again at least an hour for
parking weather delays in other parts of
the country will impact us here so keep
that in mind and take a look at your
layover flight and also your final
destination
across the nation we're expecting this
to be a heavily traveled thanksgiving
holiday obviously more so than last year
more people are more comfortable flying
you know with the vaccine being more
readily available
so also if you're expecting loved ones
here at the airport again flights are
just coming in from the red eye flights
it's recommended that you wait in the
cell phone lot it's free to wait there
until they are here at passenger pickup
and also if you have lingering questions
visit our website eightnewsnow.com
again give yourself at least two hours
if someone's dropping you off or three
hours if you plan to come here and park
once again lot
one terminal one parking is full it is
at capacity you're going to have to park
at terminal 3 or the economy lot bianca
holmen live local now oh boy or call up
that uber or taxi this morning that'll
help too there's gonna be a lot of
demand for that as well bianca thank you
very much enjoy the potential cinnabon
consumption oh